Even if you get higher education,
no, almost no major can
actually prepare you
to today's job market and and workplaces.
Those are the place that kind of give you
the skills and teach you the hands on.
Noa Ohayon Bab,
thank you so much for taking time out
of your busy schedule to be with me.
How are you?
Great.
I'm really happy and excited
to join you today.
Thank you very, very much.
Noah, if I begin to list
the different things that you've done,
the 20 minutes would be fast over.
But just for reference,
so that we can structure
the conversation a little bit.
You're running marketing
for a startup, Colu.
You're head of community
for then for eBay.
Today you're the head of the
Israeli delegation to Washington, DC.
But you're also a speechwriter
for a very famous politicians,
which you managed to put in
your children's names in there
from time to time, right?
But one of the most important things,
I think, is that you competed against
on a [--] on a trivia game show.
We did indeed. And lost.
And lost.
Tell me about that experience.
You're in "Who's the last standing", right?
Yes.
Yes, true.
And I was petrified
being in front of the basketball player.
And I'm like, "Oh,
they're going to ask me
some question about sports."
And if there is something I'm not good at
it's sports questions.
And I end up losing
to a question about a book,
which is my passion,
my hobby, my major.
You studied literature.
Yes. That was very true.
I would say it's not a very good one.
It's not a very good book,
the one that I missed.
So, I'm kind of okay with
losing on that one.
But I love it.
I love it.
Noa, even when I was listing the things,
and it's important for me
not to have anything written
because I try to be spontaneous.
But I forgot to mention that you also
just casually co-founded
one of the leading job search platforms
in Israel, which we'll get to as well.
But Noa, talk to me
about your life journey,
because that's fascinating.
You're starting out with literature.
You're writing speeches
for famous politicians,
which I want to hear
about what that's like.
And then, you all of a sudden
find yourself in the tech scene.
So, start from the speech writing
and then let's move on to the tech scene.
So, if we again smoother,
I actually started as an educator
because like everybody else,
I wanted to change the world for better.
I guess I just want
to make the world a better place.
And they said, well,
education would be "it" probably, right?
Especially in Israel
when you have so many
minority groups and such a huge gap
in between certain populations.
So, I said, "Okay, I'm going
to deep dive into that."
My original kind of ambition would be
like the minister of education.
And then I said,
"A teacher would be a good start." I'd say.
And I thought that would be
the most effective way.
Everybody goes through
the education system,
at the same time, also working
in the big philanthropy organization
with
students,
that came from disadvantaged background,
kind of enabled them
to get higher education
and get the best out of that time period.
And while I was doing all that,
for sure impact, I still felt that I was
kind of restrained in between these
literally four walls sometimes.
And I felt that if I
in person want to get
a jump start, but also with the impact,
I want to create, tech would be it.
It's this is the way to go.
If we want to prepare
the generation of the future,
we should definitely
skill them up with those areas.
And I felt that would be
the best thing to do.
And because I had that social media
as a non-profit startup, I'd say,
I was pretty good with everything
related to social media
and online marketing.
And so, that was kind of my ticket
to make that transition.
But I do have to say, Noa,
I'm stumped for a second
because that's exactly the point
that I keep thinking about.
It's about, while you just talked
about what was the scale, right?
You're saying, I'm making an impact,
it's between four walls.
Every minute that I put into a day,
you can pretty much know,
okay, this is the impact
that I'm producing.
And how do I now make
this impact at scale
so that I can impact millions of people?
And I'm sure that the work
that you were doing
with the students
physically in front of you,
you changed their lives.
But then you would think,
okay, how can I now do this at scale
and change millions
of people's lives, right?
Yeah, exactly.
So, scaling is it, you know.
Tech and scale is that so.
It's kind of doing automation of impact,
I would say.
And so, that kind of that's how
I made the transition into tech.
Obviously this can be
a whole conversation to itself
because I know many people
have that kind of ambition
to do that transition to both ways.
I get it out of course from people
who want to do the other way around.
And also, it's there's the language,
it's not just the language.
Translating your resume from,
let's say, Hebrew to English.
It's translating your resume from English
to tackle whatever language it is.
And each sector has its own lingo,
and kind of in a world.
It's like classic
with our minister of technology
moving from VC to the public sector.
But you're right,
the transition is both ways.
But yeah. Sorry, I keep interrupting you.
That's what I told you,
I want to hear more about you
than speak about myself,
but will do the other around this time.
And yeah, so I started off at in tech,
in the FinTech startup, which was
completely out of my comfort zone.
And I do give a huge kudos to this startup
that saw the potential in me.
And it was kind of a smart move also
from my end to give an opportunity
to an early stage startup,
because this is also kind of a tip
for people who were seeking
to do that transition.
And it was the best
school I could think of
working in a startup.
Especially in Israel,
it's like there's 30 hours a day
or 36 hours a day instead of 24.
It's you learn so much.
And it was literally the best school.
And I do believe that
employers,
and also companies
are the schools of today,
if we mentioned education and so on.
So, even if you get higher education, no,
almost no major can actually prepare you
to today's job market and workplaces.
Those are the place to kind of
give you the skills
and teach you the hands-on work.
So, yeah, so that was
kind of the first step.
And all along I kept on having
my job search platform,
which I co-founded
with a friend named Dana.
And yeah, which also kind of
made it very loud and clear
because I was talking to job seekers
to thousands and tens of thousands
and even more of job seekers,
but at the same times to employers.
And I could see very clearly
kind of this gap between
you write your resume, hope for the best,
do whatever you can
to put yourself into words,
and then you send them out
and hope that someone gets them.
But we all know that
even if they get them,
they get a chance to read so few of them.
So, that's kind of definitely
a market disruption
that I care a lot about.
And obviously, I have to say
that you're being very
humble by just saying
that you co-founded this platform.
This is one of the most popular platforms
in Israel for job searching with hundreds
of thousands of visitors per month
and tens of thousands
of active engagements.
And we're talking about here
people's lives, people's livelihoods.
This is not just another product.
This is literally finding people jobs.
For some people,
it's to get food on the table.
For others,
it's for different fulfillment.
So, that's incredible.
Noa, you moved from Colu to eBay.
And now you're about community
and you're about engagement.
What does that mean to you?
So, first of all, thank you so
for putting that in such good wording,
because people keep on asking.
I've been doing it for over than 10 years
and we have a group of seven volunteers
and people are like,
why are you doing it?
We do it voluntarily.
We don't, we're not for this.
Amazing.
We're not getting paid.
And when people ask me,
"Do you not feeling...?"
In Hebrew there's a special word for it,
fry or fly, which means:
do you not feel like you could get
you're able to get so
much money out of this?
And I'm like, I want to make sure
I keep it free for both sides.
So people, so organization
will be more than happy
to send us as many jobs as possible,
especially during covid.
At the same time,
we're going to keep it free
for those who are job seeking.
And we all know that that can be
the toughest time out of someone's lives.
Yeah.
So, if you're actually about community,
so, you know, this is pretty smooth
because if we're talking about community,
I guess it's exactly it.
It's being able to,
in a way to advance your life.
And I do think when you talk about
online communities and Facebook
and social media, many of the times
you would hear people
criticize it and say
it's shallow and it's a waste of time
and it's only self bragging and so on.
And I do believe that
we can use social media
and even online marketing
to benefit our life,
to become better parents.
I get a ton of advice.
I'm sure I'm a better mom
since I've been using mom groups
and parents groups online,
and it makes us better professionals.
And honestly, it's just
it's I do believe this is the way to go.
And if you talk about
companies and tech companies,
I think for everyone it is very clear
that old days, marketing,
the one that you think of a slogan
of a catch phrase,
you think of the best image,
it's just not enough.
None of us is going to make enough vision
of what cell phone to buy
because they have Galgadot, which I love.
Yeah, I don't want to [--].
All of us do.
But it's just not enough.
I'm not going to get someone
just because they have
an amazingly beautiful face on it.
I'm going to do it because,
because I'm going to find this blog
or just a friend or a Facebook group
that I appreciate and I'm going to search
and I'm going to see some reviews
and make up my mind based on that
more than anything else.
And this goes for honestly,
almost everything you do
if you think about it.
And also studies shows that 40%
of the consumer choice we made
are based on ear to mouth.
And this is how
we make our choices today.
And that's why reviews are so big.
And so many startups
and companies are around reviews.
But at the same time,
community and consumer community
or a product community,
this is honestly this is the way you go.
And eBay, the boss I had,
which is also a funny story,
he heard me interviewed
on another podcast
about online communities.
And when the site in Israel wanted
to try and kind of put up a team for that,
they were looking for a team leader.
And so, he heard me on that podcast
and so he reached out.
And it was so funny because
it was exactly that
they wanted to do this experiment
where they take their users,
their product users around a certain area
and kind of build the community around it
and see how we curate products better,
how we create an inner community.
Let's say,
if it's buyers on eBay or Amazon,
how do you create their own
inner community to share your problem,
best practices and so on.
That is fascinating.
I think that what you said before,
which really resonated with me,
you said that the pretty face
and the logo and the message,
is it's not enough.
And I hear some people say that
that branding and marketing has changed.
I don't think the change is about it.
What you're saying is
it's evolved, right?
It is still important.
It's still important to have
the great people presenting it.
The messaging is important,
the logo is important.
But now for me to want
to buy a cell phone,
to for me to want
to engage with the product,
I need something more.
I need to feel a part of the community.
And I think that
that's just something fascinating
that really feels like it's something
out of the last five or six years, right?
That it's really becoming more
and more common,
which is, I think, incredible.
But I want to make sure we have enough
time also to talk about
what you're doing today.
Because today you're talking
from Washington DC, right?
Yes.
What are you doing there?
Yeah, basically kind of the same,
but just different.
The idea is to have
a Israel representative
live here in America,
working with the community
here in America
and kind of working on the connection
between Israel
and working on that relationship
to kind of make it more depth
than what you hear on the news
and
on social media.
So, this is kind of depict the deep
relationship in between.
And, yeah, I'm leading a group here
and also moved here with my family
on this adventure.
Again, following passion, I guess.
And I definitely love doing that.
And I do believe that in some aspects
we can definitely,
some aspects and best practices,
we can bring from outside of the country
here to America and definitely learn
from different cultures.
I can say that
Facebook groups in Israel are so big.
Studies show that people in Israel
spend their time,
at least in two or three Facebook group
and really
consumer, but also for every
other aspect in their life.
And when we had a session
or a committee of people
who lead big community groups
and communities online through Facebook.
So, we met there GM of Israel
and she said that Israel is really
the kind of the top of that pyramid
with innovation around kind of committee.
I guess, because, you know,
it's a good sandbox with those things.
It's a small place.
Everybody knows everyone.
And definitely, yeah.
So again, you're taking community.
But you're going from tech
now back to community.
And I'm guessing that
there is a little bit of a difference
between running the community
and engagement for a startup,
then for a big corporation and now
for more of the government
and more for social issues, right?
Yeah.
And even maybe,
even diplomate in a way.
But I can tell you that throughout
the last decade that I've been doing it
in different aspects, you can see
that some of the essence run the same.
I mean, people want to find their peers
or people they can relate to.
They want to get knowledgeable
from those areas.
And I'd say I think kind of a difference
between a non-community
or a community is kind of,
or between the old marketing
and the new marketing
will be around two things:
one of them would be
that the communication is both ways.
It's not just a company or organization
or a social cause shouting
out their message,
it goes both ways.
And that one I can speak very close
from working in a startup
because you have your roadmap.
And the product team have their plans
and not want to hear any feedback
from up the street.
And kind of make a good buddy from work
a good community manager
and a more advanced marketer.
You would bring that information
back to the team.
I can give you just a tiny example.
When I work for PolyPay,
it's a payment app like Venmo.
And it was new.
Five years ago in Israel,
no one used a payment app.
I remember.
I remember when it was brand new.
Yeah.
So, okay. So thank you.
You probably got tons of emails from me.
You know from Colu, it was me.
And I said no one used it
and we had to educate the market.
And so we asked people,
why don't you feel confident?
We ask, what's kind of your feedback?
And many of them said
they don't feel confident enough
to put in their credit card information.
And so we just added the symbol,
that icon of lock.
And even that just increased the trust
in maybe 30% when it happened.
And it's just a tiny example
of how feedback from users
can really change
your product and your everything.
And so that's one major thing,
the two sides of communication.
And the other thing is,
to create a space for people
to communicate with each other.
And that also was a good thing.
Because if you're talking
about a tech product, you would say,
why is it important to ask?
But we even just spread
by widening focus group,
they have an opportunity to talk users
where they get the opportunity
to communicate between themselves,
you can actually create not just users,
but passionate community members
of your own product.
And many before me,
Yelp, they build their,
that's basically how
they build themselves up,
bottom up.
Noa, it's just fascinating.
It's so, so relevant
to everything that's happening today
and the whole evolution
of the company's brand
engagement community,
it's just fascinating
work that you're doing.
And I just love how you are
getting all these different,
extraordinary experiences.
Half of which we didn't even get
to really dive deep in and talk about.
And that's why I keep beating myself
on the head that I that I called this,
20 Minute Leaders and not
30 minute leaders.
Because oftentimes
I just want to continue.
But unfortunately, I have to now
thank you for being so generous
with your time.
And I have to ask you the last question,
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
So, I would say the first one
would probably be passion.
I hope it goes through it.
I am passionate in everything I do,
I'd say probably
the second thing would be community.
It's something I care a lot
through everything I do.
And the third one,
which I had the hardest time choosing,
maybe because it's the last one,
I'd say maybe
adjustable
or kind of-
Yeah.
Yeah. Being-
Dynamic. Adjustable.
Yeah.
Because, you know,
people translate what Darwin said.
And they sometimes you hear
someone said that he said
that the stronger survives.
But if you look closely
at the translation, it says,
that it was more adaptive
that's who survives.
And I think that's kind of our generation
and our future generation,
and the reality that we live today,
being adaptive and being able to adjust
to whatever comes your way,
that's kind of the way
to survive, I guess.
But also to enjoy, not just surviving.
Yeah.
Noah, toda raba. Thank you so, so much.
This was just wonderful.
Thank you for the incredible work
that you're doing,
whether it's helping
thousands of people find jobs
or helping spread the message of Israel
in a better light
and in a more correct light
with actual deep meaning.
And not just headlines from either sides.
And I'm just looking forward to continue
learning from you, from all your journey
and continue maintaining
this relationship.
So, thank you very much.
Same here.
Thank you so much.